at denver colorado one more time final
game in this three-game series
rangers and rockies and the rangers
going for the sweep and for john gray
he's been
itching to get back out there one of the
toughest things about being a starting
pitcher jeff houston
is if you have one that you're not proud
of you have to wait
five days so you can get back out and
rectify what occurred in his last outing
i think that's where john's mindset is
shinsu had a good ball game yesterday
13 hits for the rangers and not this
time that's great to see yesterday john
tied him up at 94.
here's nick solak but it happens over a
period of time and that's that slider to
get another strikeout so a good start
for john clearly
when you strike out that many guys in
your career it just becomes who you are
colby allard making his third start of
the year it's been really good so far
those first two just one earned run
allowed in nine innings pitched
i always worry about having a little bit
too much energy feeling too strong but
looks pretty good here
in his first played appearance against
hanson now trevor story who had a huge
night last night
two strike pitch to story got him
swinging
back-to-back strikeouts for allard to
start the day
i'll bring up charlie blackman wind up
in the pitch
and a swing and a miss and allard
strikes out the side in order in the
first
fraser who had yesterday off he's riding
a nine-game hitting streak
in the air center field that ball
carrying pretty well
and it's off the fence hampson traps it
with his body basically
near the fence and frazier will settle
for the double
just missed getting that one out and
here's rookie
that ball pounded out to right field
will it stay fair
it is gone a two run
shot for rodor and the rangers take the
early lead
the hands the elbow the path of the
swing and
rookie watching that one really closely
and hoping that it wouldn't hook and it
didn't
that'll bring up rymel tapia there's a
winning eb how about that tapia lines
the ball to left center field
kemp to second that's a great at bat
from rhymel
so ryan mcmahon two outs and two on
and this ball's in the air deep center
field did he click it
you bet ryan mcmahon left on left just
gave the rockies a lead
a three-run jack to center
that's the right man everybody
trevor story the eighth man to hit come
up with two on
trevor pops this up this is in no man's
land oh door nobody's gonna catch it
the rockies get a freebie hampshire to
third
i'm telling you all series even if it's
not an error
texas has been big time shaky
defensively
now blackman at the plate same situation
first
and third pulled hard past dietrich
that'll score run story on his way to
third
and now charlie's going to try to move
up and
that turned out to be a poor decision
he's mad for himself
jeff mathis nine one and two for texas
pulled to nolan what a play now can he
throw him back
oh my goodness what a play that was
just add that again to the human
highlight reel
that we call nolan being no nolan that
is as good as it gets going to your
backhand
so two away for tapia now
and this ball is in the air deep left
center field that outfield on the run
they're not gonna catch this one
matt kemp's gonna get a green light from
stu cole and
matt's going to score easily toward
third is tapia with a triple
make it 6-2 here come the rockies again
with two outs
and here's joey gallo
in the air out to right field it's not
coming back that is rocky mountain high
and it is gone gallow with his fifth
home run of the year
so they get one back it's 6-3 story at
the plate
trevor drives us to center field base
hit hanson with the ball out in front of
him easily will head to third now here
comes story
trying to beat the throw and he will
hampson coming home he'll score
how do you like that speed kicks away
story to third
speed kills rockies
get a run back seven to three dory at
third
charlie will try to produce his second
ribby of the day
and this will get it done into the right
field corner story come
on down charlie heading to second
bobbled for a moment by gallow
blackman with his second hit of the ball
game 22 rbis and the rockies have an
eight to three lead one out and that'll
bring up drew butera
[Applause]
[Music]
down the left field line captain stroll
home
trail runner top yet he'll stroll home
two run double drew butera and the
rockies have hit double digits
pinch hitter for jeff mathis isaiah
keiner
falefa and he's walked in a run
santana who just came in in the eighth
he's gonna get his second at bat today
and he walked in another run 10-4 to
begin the inning
two runs walked in by jairo diaz so with
two out scott heinemann
is coming to bat and and that's back
at esteban it hit him and that'll end
the ball game
the rockies survive 10 to 6.